india is in the throes of the ultimate
covet catastrophe
recording more infections per day just
short of 400
000 at the moment officially than any
other country since the pandemic began
with hospitals at breaking point forced
to turn patients away and
oxygen running out the death rate climbs
relentlessly
sick people and their families search
desperately for help
and for answers how did it come to this
is the government to blame
coronavirus in india out of control
welcome to to the point it is a pleasure
to welcome our guests
my dw colleague biresh banerjee works in
our asia department
and says accountability must follow this
disaster
and tobias court is also with us here in
the studio he's professor of public
health
and epidemiology at berlin's charity
hospital and he says the devastating
situation in india should remind us that
the covet 19 pandemic
is far from over and that we need to
make all efforts to control the spread
of the disease on a global level
and finally it's wonderful to have with
us
joining us remotely from delhi ankita
mukho padilla she is dw's correspondent
in india and she says the indian
government's blame game and
mismanagement of the pandemic
has unnecessarily endangered millions
of innocent lives
let me begin uh by asking you
ankita i know that you yourself lost
a family member in this wave of the
pandemic so can you tell us
a little bit about the current situation
uh as you're experiencing it
yes um i'll just give a brief about what
happened
exactly so my husband's father died from
covert 19. uh he would have lived harry
caught a hospital bed on time
uh he was a senior officer with the
government of india he got the virus
from a colleague in office
after which when his oxygen levels fell
to 93 we tried to get him admitted
to a government hospital uh which is
supposed to take in patients
who people people who work for the
government but he did not get a pet on
time
and by the time he got a bed his
situation was quite bad and then
his tongues were more than 50 infected
so but that's the situation at least he
got a bed right now the current
situation is that
people are scrambling for basic uh
things like medicines
uh oxygen uh there are peas coming on in
social media handles
every day uh i recently got uh my
grandfather recently was outside a
hospital for two hours with 70
uh that was his level of oxygen uh
fighting for his life
and there was no bed given to him he had
to you know uh
uh sit in the hospital corridor waiting
for a bed
uh that's how bad the situation is and
many people are dying at home
uh because they're unable to get access
to basic resources
that number that i mentioned 400 000 new
infections a day
uh it's always emphasized that these
numbers
are probably incorrect and that the
inofficial tally tallies much higher can
you take a guess at what it could be
uh according to a research by iit daddy
i
think they said that the death tally is
uh
probably somewhere right now i think the
government is saying it's 204
832. um iit is saying it's it's in
millions uh they did not give an exact
figure uh they're estimating that it
could uh
reach around like uh four or five
million over the next one or two
months and that is a conservative
estimate because the problem is that a
lot of the debts
uh because of forward 19 are not being
deported
uh a lot of the funeral homes uh like
for example when we
i went to do the funeral of my
father-in-law
uh we were told that uh if we don't
classify it as a covet 19 death then we
can do a normal funeral
uh that's just one case that i'm talking
about and i'm sure there are
uh that there's this mass funerals
happening
uh there are so many people who are uh
going into hospitals and getting the
cover 19 infection so if say someone
uh like a lady recently she was pregnant
uh gave birth in the hospital and got
over 19
and died but uh there is the end uh
the death report did not state that
another big issue is that hospitals are
accountable
if they have more reports from forward
19. so the cops cops are getting
involved if there are deaths from covert
19
which is why a lot of the hospitals do
not want to report uh deaths from
poverty
thank you very much uh ankita let me go
to beer i should ask you what you're
hearing from home
things are bad things are as bad as it
can be and just to give you an idea of
how bad
they are at the start of the week you
had the federal government telling
people in delhi
to wear masks sitting in their homes now
imagine that you cannot trust the air
you breathe in your own home
in the national capital of the biggest
democracy
on the planet a country that is one of
the top 10 economies
in the world and that really gives you
just a bit of a hint
of the magnitude of this disaster and
the word disaster melinda
doesn't even cover what is happening in
india it is
adjectives combined and still short it
is a tragedy it's a horror story it's a
disaster it's an embarrassment
and it's still short of describing what
is happening there you heard ankita
talking there
uh just to point out uh the under
counting of deaths in the manner in
which
uh ankita described that was happening
last year as well
i have friends who suffered from govern
to give you an example a friend of mine
was at a crematorium for his uncle's
funeral
last year and last year crematorium
workers were saying we have never
cremated so many bodies in one
day and exactly what ankita mentioned if
you want the death registered
as a covet 19 death which is to say it
says that on the death certificate
it means the state takes over and you
can't even touch the body
of your uh your loved one you cannot
wave them a final goodbye which is
strange because now that is what is
happening
automatically so a strong incentive
there to not
register covet 19 deaths dr kurt let me
ask
you about the discussion around
this new variant of the virus b1617
there's a lot of discussion but
apparently
no clear answers on whether this is
responsible
for the surge we're seeing in india this
variant apparently
is not only more contagious but possibly
also can dodge
the immune systems of people who have
already
been vaccinated known as a breakthrough
infection
do you think that's what's behind this
first of all
it's important to understand that in the
course of a virus infection variants are
developing so if many many people are
infected that's exactly what we see in
india right now
there's a high chance that the virus
mutates so there's a new variant so
i think we're not talking about one
variant in india there's several
variants right now which makes the
situation even more complex
and uh it's also difficult to really
analyze the data
precisely so how much more does it
spread how much
more dangerous is it does it give a more
severe disease
or is it allowing even people who are
immune against the wild type to be
reinfected
so that's very difficult if you have a
disaster in a country like how can you
do research
while people are dying on every corner
so to say so we have to be
a calm but be very careful in looking at
the data
and also seeing whether this then also
applies to other settings because
a variant spreads in a specific setting
it wins
so to say because it spreads more likely
doesn't mean it spreads in other
settings too
not necessarily so we have to be
watching but i think right now the
situation
needs other action and and hopefully
that we can solve this
spread soon i want to come back to some
of the facts about what we know and keep
that please
yeah yeah i just want to add to this uh
a lot of people in india are right now
taking medications which are not
prescribed for forward 19 they are
doing it from hearsay they are doing it
you're hearing about it in social media
that's dangerous because you don't know
how the body will react there are people
who are taking steroids at home
without without it being administered by
a doctor uh i was myself told by a lot
of people to take medicines like
ivermectin and doxycycline which are not
proven
uh to be effective against the
coronavirus so this is what is happening
happening right now let me ask you uh
ankit
and kita because um correct me if i'm
wrong but
until not too long ago it looked like
india was actually doing
pretty well it locked down it absorbed
the first wave
of the virus and maintained a pretty low
official
death rate what went wrong
what looks there are a lot of reasons uh
the first one obviously is that the
government was very confident that
uh we have a high recovery date so uh
even if the infection spreads it it
won't be an issue
what they did not estimate was that
there will be a lot of deaths from
basic necessities a lot of the people uh
their oxygen levels even if they
fluctuate slightly they do need medical
attention
uh they do need oxygen and they did the
government
did not estimate the need uh or that
will arise
uh if the mutation spreads the other
issue is that this cup this particular
government the bjp government
does not take the advice of experts
seriously it does not take uh data
seriously
it fudges data it is very uh brutal in
clamping down on people criticizing the
government
so there have been calls since last year
to not get rid of makeshift feds
uh to not send vaccines to other
countries when people in india
themselves are unable to get vaccinated
and now the action that the government
is taking it's not enough they're asking
the prime minister of india asked people
to stay at home
uh in mid-april when he gave a speech
but yesterday he tweeted saying that we
people in the state of west bengal
should go vote
uh to celebrate the festival of
democracy
which uh even why would you even ask
people to go vote when you know the
situation is so bad even if you ask them
to vote under covert 19 protocols
thank you very much and i want to come
back to that in just a moment but beerus
let me come to you because your
opening statement talked about the need
for accountability
and i'd like to talk a little bit about
accountability
on the part of whom and for what let's
take a look at these pictures uh that
were taken two weeks ago
during the festival of mela
this is the largest religious pilgrimage
in the world
i'm hoping we can guess there we go
there we have the pictures uh
the largest religious pilgrimage in the
world millions
congregate in the city of haidwa not a
lot of social distancing going on there
didn't many citizens simply let their
guard down
citizens of course did let their guard
down but then you must understand that
the kum mela
has a central place in the religious and
the cultural life
of india what needs to be pointed out
here is that this particular miller in
haridwar was actually scheduled for next
year
it was brought forward this year on the
advice of astrologers
that is how important the advice of
astrologers is
for this government over the advice of
scientists and just to go back to the
double mutation that trevius was talking
about
the first reports of this double
mutation emerged in october last year
and the kumbh miller went ahead in
january for two and a half months you
had these visuals
on a daily basis and these are people
who come from all corners of india
and then go back to those corners of
india just to give you an idea of how
important this is and how infectious and
what a super spreader event this is
the former king and queen of nepal who
visited kumela
went back to nepal and they were
diagnosed with kovid just last week
that is how much of a super spreader
event this was and the question
needs to be asked why was this allowed
to go ahead why was this brought forward
by a year
on the advice of astrologers at a time
when the first reports of a double
mutation had emerged
in india in october and then in january
you have the prime minister saying
to the world economic conference india
has done a fantastic job
fighting back the covet pandemic using a
people-centric approach
looking at the visuals coming out of
just delhi there is nothing
people-centric about that
tobias court should prime minister modi
have seen this health crisis
coming as we've heard from both bires
and ankita
he was saying not too long ago that the
country was
in great shape now we are hearing
doctors your colleagues begging the
prime minister for help for oxygen for
medicines for support
should he have not seen that the
country's medical system would hit a
wall
well we know that scientists
are alarming since months and months and
months we know that this can happen this
can happen anywhere else in the world
too there's a specific setting in india
with that many people
housing situation close activities so
it's not a surprise that this
disaster right now is happening and yes
the politician
should be aware of this and should have
been aware of this and should be
advising the public
to react differently and not allowing
such super spread events and now
obviously it's much much too late and
and any country with the best healthcare
system in the world would
not managing that many people getting
sick and that many people
dying that's just not possible for any
healthcare system
and and particularly in india right now
it's it's really dramatic and we have to
hopefully get international support the
situation can be stabilized talk to us a
little bit about the indian
health care system i was looking at uh
some statistics and apparently india
spends a little over one percent
of its gross domestic product on health
how does that compare to other emerging
economies and also to what the
who recommends in terms of public health
spending well you always can do more
for sure and each country is well aware
that health is an important
factor for its population and but as i
said if you have
that disaster that many people getting
ill
and sick and severely sick and dying you
could have spent
20 percent it would not be enough
that's really a disaster and and so
that's why it is so important that we
understand on the global level
also in germany that this can happen and
we have to be very aware
of ways to avoid this um beerus you were
talking about bringing forth
bringing forward kumela on the basis of
astrologer astrology uh
recommendations and so on even as the
country's health system
was wobbling and doctors were
issuing those appeals that i mentioned
prime minister modi
himself was holding large political
rallies
at which he declined to wear a mask
is he the super spreader in chief well
he has been called the super spreader by
the vice president of the indian medical
association
the collective of doctors in the country
but to be fair it wasn't just prime
minister modi and the bjp that were
organizing rallies
in the four states and one union
territory that i that have gone to the
polls it was other political parties as
well
and herein lies the big dilemma i
remember in the u.s elections uh
president joe biden
then candidate joe biden was holding car
rallies that is something you can't do
in indian elections people can't drive
up in their cars
and even even if they could afford those
cars you'd have millions of cars
coming in a political rally so it's just
physically not doable what was required
was creative thinking and imagination
on the part of the government and the
part of the election commission of india
to try and say look this is an
extraordinary situation
we need to find some way in which we can
do this that conversation was never had
so the super spreader events yes each
political rally from each
party uh was responsible for uh the
spread of this virus
but as the leader of the country with 74
popularity the country looks to you for
leadership
where was that leadership especially
when you were not even wearing masks
at massive rallies that were organized
in all these states
and keith um we just heard from
beerus the mention of the u.s election
campaign in fact if we look at prime
minister modi's
denialism and magical thinking it
doesn't seem
all that different from some of what we
heard from former president
donald trump in the u.s or from boris
johnson uh prime minister uh
in in britain um but things have gone
so much worse in india why is that
the the thing about india is that uh
right now the government is looking for
reasons to
uh divert the minds of the people
because at the end of the day they are
looking at their vote base
uh their vote base is still supporting
uh the bjp government uh
the the kum mela the election rallies
all play into
into that uh if you have a religious
gathering you're pandering to
uh everyone's religious interests uh if
you're targeting say
jamaat were targeted last year and not
talk talking about the camilla sort of
addressing the fact that the government
is still a hindu nationalist government
and the elections obviously are a way
for people to forget about what's
happening
so uh with a a prime minister of a
country like india uh should have not
been uh
should have actually asked people asked
the health care system or invested in it
long ago and we actually raised money
there was a pm cash fund for
himself asked people to raise money
where did that money go there was no
there's been no accountability and i
think right now with this humanitarian
crisis
there needs to be a systemic change in
india and people have to call for it but
are people going to call for it is the
question because
there are still calls uh just they still
believe that modi will come back
probably with a bigger mandate
let me ask beerush whether he thinks
people are going to call for it uh
ankita and also you have both made it
clear that the impact
of this crisis is being felt not only by
the poorest as during the first
wave of kovid but by the middle class as
well
will there be a backlash against the
government that could make itself
felt politically do you think you you
talked about accountability
do you think they will demand
accountability by
at the polls i think everybody who's
dying is demanding accountability even
if they're not
articulating it in that fashion but the
polls is the only place i think in
in the in present-day india where
accountability can be demanded
the next major polls are in the state of
uttar pradesh in about
eight months i believe that is going to
be the litmus test for whether people
remember and here's the thing about
india and this comes from my experiences
having been born there and brought up
there and having worked there as a
journalist
in india you have to dust yourself off
get up
and live the next day and in eight
months that's a lot of days
and 2024 the next general election when
modi stands for re-election potentially
is is a long way off i worry
internally that these calls for
accountability
will potentially be forgotten in the
months
in between and you are talking about a
country where
the bjp government the ruling party has
a well-oiled election machinery
a well-oiled perception machinery on
social media
and appliant media and absent opposition
the opportunities are rife for this
government to swing the narrative
in another month or so in leading up to
the first polls in 2022 in uttar pradesh
so i really don't know if that
accountability will be delivered at the
ballot box
but i really think that the people of
the country need to think
if they will not hold the government
accountable for this
when the government expects patients to
carry their own oxygen cylinder
and come into a hospital for treatment
if
this doesn't turn the tide or
force people to demand accountability i
don't know what will
let us now um talk about
whether there is also accountability to
be demanded from the international
community and the fact is as the
situation
spirals out of control in india the
first wave of medical aid from the eu
and the united states is now beginning
to reach the country ventilators oxygen
and the raw materials for vaccines are
trickling
in but as beerus just mentioned for many
the help
comes too late
once a parking lot this crematorium is
now the final destination for hundreds
of victims of covet 19.
our ngo goes to the homes of victims of
coven 19 who died in quarantine
and brings them here to be cremated the
government only counts covet 19 related
deaths of victims who die in a hospital
and all others are unaccounted for
while the pyres burn day and night help
from around the world is on the way
in new delhi ventilators and other
medical supplies arrive from abroad
elsewhere tanks full of oxygen rush
through the night for patients in
desperate need
german chancellor angela merkel says
it's just the beginning
above all else we will see what we can
do to help india
we are now working at full speed to see
to what extent we can bring oxygen
producing plants there
all of europe is behind this for health
workers in the country's overwhelmed
hospitals
that help can't come soon enough
what do i do what do i do there is no
physical space we put him on
whatever support we can they're trying
to organize a bed somewhere or another
on the front lines against covet 19
doctors and patients are measuring time
and breaths
not days or weeks
dr court india is actually the world's
vaccine powerhouse it makes 60 percent
of the world's vaccines and it's home to
major manufacturers including the serum
institute which is the largest vaccine
manufacturer
in the world yet the pace of vaccination
has been quite sluggish vaccines are now
being diverted for domestic use vaccines
that otherwise
would have gone to africa so two
questions
do we have a possible domino effect here
if those vaccines aren't going
elsewhere and secondly why is it
that india actually hasn't gotten the
raw materials
needed to make vaccines because they're
being held back for example by the
united states
very good question important to
understand this it's a global pandemic
pandemic is on the global level if we
want to control it we need to vaccinate
people as quickly as possible
everywhere in the world including india
of course it is not reasonable to hold
back any material if you say okay
my country first i need to vaccinate my
people it's short-sighted because this
will come back in the very end that is
not being addressable by this vaccine on
the market so we need to modify the
vaccine and so on
we need to make sure that production
signs are all over the world including
india and that can be used locally
to vaccine as many people as possible so
it's really dramatic we all speak about
global health the importance of global
health but if we have a global health
crisis exactly that does not really work
well
and keith uh we saw that report help
is now trickling into india if you
listen to what european and u.s
leaders have been saying since the
pandemic began there's been a lot of lip
service paid to the idea that no one is
safe till everyone's safe
but the reality on the ground is that
many nations have take
and taken a nation first strategy do you
really think that's changing
i wouldn't completely believe that see
uh the health is
trickling in and uh and that's great
because a lot of the nations are
thinking about india but
the political situation is such right
now is that the new variant uh
it's uh killing a lot of people under
40. uh the indian government did not
expect anything like this uh
they were not prepared for this kind of
a wave and now uh
the 20 liters and vaccines that are
coming in it may be too late
uh because infection has spread in a lot
of people
another issue is that
another issue that we are facing is that
with the vaccines
uh the uh the vaccine that we exported
we were trying to have a vaccine
diplomacy where we were trying to show
that okay
we we have a lot of vaccine and we can
export and now with the raw materials
coming in there's so much of hard work
in proctoring the raw materials the
indian government is simply going to use
as
an opportunity to charge people okay so
i'm afraid i'm going to have to stop you
there thank you so much beerus
one half sentence is it too late are we
seeing this spiral
out of control now i think it is too
late it's going to get worse before it
gets better
thank you very much thanks to all of you
for being with us thank you to ankita in
daily thanks to both of you and thanks
to our viewers
see you soon